hey guys my name is Jess today the fifth
of July and you're tuned into guess what
Blizzard has filed a lawsuit against the
creators of an overwatch cheating
program parent freak reports that German
based company boss land created an
overwatch cheating tool called watch
over tyrants and blizzard I'm not happy
about it the tool allows players to see
the help and position of obscured
players lizard actually have a history
with bus land as they previously sued
the same company over bots which helped
users cheat in games like World of
Warcraft Paris of the storm and stabbed
like three allegedly thousands of
players may be using this tool which as
you can imagine damages the game by
giving some place an unfair advantage
Blizzard have claimed copyright
infringement and the encouragement of
unfair competition and relieved boss
lenders cost some millions of dollars in
revenue as well as a referal damage to
their goodwill and reputation our
Flanders told TorrentFreak they have not
received notice of the lawsuit as of
yesterday Xbox is adding a new
wheelchair option to its Xbox avatar
systems xbox engineering lead my cure
Barra took to Twitter to reveal images
of the new option to add a wheelchair to
your xbox avatar this came after Xbox
co-creator shameless blackley tweeted
depending on how skeletons are done on
avatars wheelchairs might be relatively
simple and the hashtag right thing that
kicked off a petition to include
wheelchairs to which Xbox boss Phil
Spencer applied there would be no need
as they'd already looked into the Avatar
inclusion the avatars on the hole
appeared to be getting the higher
fidelity treatment with more features to
come so across the board Xbox fans
should see their avatars leveling up
before too long in oh my god it's
actually happening news red dead
redemption will arrive on Xbox one this
friday through backwards compatibility
rockstar has announced that everybody's
favorite open-world westin will be
playable on the 8th of july and it's
available to Gold members for seven
dollars 50 on the Xbox store if you
don't have it or can't find it
if you don't have a gold subscription
you can pick it up the ten dollars 50 on
the Xbox feedback site there are only
two games with more votes asking for
them to be included in the backwards
compatibility catalog call of duty black
ops 2 and the Elder Scrolls 5 skyrim let
me know which xbox 360 game you're still
waiting on to arrive on xbox one be sure
to drop by gamespot for stories on fever
17 and fallout 4 and come by again
tomorrow for a bunch more news